welcome back to las vegas now according
to verizon's latest national survey the
sponsors of the segment almost half of
american consumers 42 percent plan to
reevaluate their spending ahead of
summer getting the biggest bang for your
buck is another way to stretch your
dollars tonya francisco from our sister
station in chicago show us more
we know that everyone is looking for
ways to stretch their dollar get more
bang for their buck so i've got some
really great tips on how you can get the
most out of your wireless provider okay
so where do we first start yeah so the
first thing you're going to want to do
is look for deals verizon has an amazing
offer right now and it's for all
customers whether you're a new customer
or an existing customer you can trade in
your phone and get a free 5g phone on
verizon or up to 800 towards a new phone
all right so i can get rid of this old
galaxy s9 that is probably so far
outdated that it's not even funny
absolutely whether you've got a cracked
screen or it's broken you can come in
trade it in uh and you can get this s22
uh for free i'm very my goodness this is
one of the latest models that's out
there and it's 5g absolutely connects to
our 5g ultra wide band network you get
those amazing 5g speeds
which are 10 times faster than what
you're used to what you have now
it's safer than public wi-fi and it's
amazing when you're in crowds okay so
that's if you have a phone what about
your plan yes so your my second tip is
you're going to want to get the most out
of your plan okay verizon's best 5g
unlimited plans they have up to 90
dollars of value included so think about
things like um disney plus espn plus
hulu yeah all that heads up apple music
uh google play passer apple arcade
travel pass all these services you know
you look up those really those can add
up on your bill so these are included in
our plan so if you're already paying for
these
come to come to rise and check out your
plans they might already be included in
your plan i know a big deal for a lot of
people is internet you know because when
you start adding that up into all of
your other plans they really can start
adding up as well yes and so my next tip
is when you pair your wireless service
with your home internet you can really
save so
with verizon we have home internet for
just 25 per month
when you pair it with your wireless
service on one of our latest unlimited
plans and is this fast it's amazing so
super fast speeds 300 megabits per
second down
and then we're talking about no
promotional price creep no annual
contracts no extra fees uh it really is
an amazing service and uh we hope
everyone will try it you go to
verizon.com
home
and you can plug in your address and see
if it's in your coverage area well just
for the sake of asking you got anything
else i do so uh you're gonna want to
come to the stores for this one okay uh
so on the second wednesday of every
month uh we have what we call win on
wednesday and so if you make a qualified
purchase on that day you could be
entered to win amazing entertainment
experience experiences um and uh it's
just tremendous you gotta go to the
stores for it okay we gotta go to the
store for that okay but wait i can get a
free phone i can get internet i can get
streaming services and intro sweepstakes
i mean that sounds win-win to me it's
amazing so you're going to want to go to
the stores or we have these great
express lockers so you could shop how
you want to shop at verizon but for more
information go to verizon.com deals and
and check out all of this and make sure
you're getting the most out of your
wireless provider